Okay.
People have been asking for me to bring this
back.
I did it a few months ago.
People loved it.
I'm going to do it again.
I am doing book recommendations today.
I've been reading a ton.
I was recently on vacation and I read three
books while I was in Aruba.
The David Pakman show book recommendation
page is back David pakman.com/recommendations
I'm going to make a new found effort to keep
it updated and you can now, once again, this
has been gone for years.
You can support the David Pakman show when
you buy the books.
I recommend using the links at David pakman.com/recommendations
by the way, now I have to be very careful
in how I say this.
If you click on one of the links at David
pakman.com/recommendations and you don't end
up buying one of the books, I recommend that
you buy something else.
That also supports the David Pakman show.
I'm being very careful in the language that
I use.
All right.
Here's, let's start, I'm going to give you
two nonfiction books in two fiction books.
I just finished this two days ago.
American kingpin.
Okay.
The epic hunt for the criminal masterminds
behind the Silk Road.
It is extraordinarily well written by Nick
Bilton.
I think I read this in three days.
It's close to 400 pages.
I was so sucked in by it that over the long
holiday weekend Labor Day weekend, I read
this in like three days.
This book number one is just a caper of the
highest, uh, level.
Um, in catching Ross Ulbricht, the creator
of the Silk Road, a dark web website on which
firearms and drugs were bought and sold.
It shows how clever some people in law enforcement
can be, and it also shows us the dysfunction
that exists between different law enforcement
agencies and intelligence agencies.
You know, we hear, oh, they don't work well
together.
This book, aside from just being extremely
an extremely entertaining read, it sucked
me in from the first page.
Uh, it also shows the dysfunction that exists
between agencies.
So get this one.
David pakman.com/recommendations American
kingpin, the hunt for the criminal masterminds
behind the Silk Road.
My second nonfiction recommendation for you
today is plutocrats plutocrats by Christina
Freeland.
This is a book about without making ad hominems
and without placing too many value judgements
on things.
It's a book about the development and growth
of this sort of plutocratic overclass in American
and world society.
It deals with oligarch types in other countries.
It talks about tax policy.
It talks about a lot of the different political
and financial elements that have led to much
of the inequality that we now have.
It's not just inequality in terms of money.
The book points out.
It's also inequality in terms of access to
education, which is related to money and other
things.
Okay.
Plutocrats by Christina Freeland, David pakman.com/recommendations
use the links there to get it.
Okay.
Now two fiction books of brand new one and
then a classic.
I read this during my vacation in Aruba a
couple of weeks ago, Delta v by Daniel Suarez.
This is much like American kingpin is a real
life Kapor.
This is a Psi Phi, uh, outer space sort of
caper.
It is an extremely interesting book, a lot
of science in it, which in no way makes it
feel like a slog in any way.
The book moves, I think it took me like five
days to read it.
Of course I was just sitting on the beach
everyday reading.
It's easy to get through books that way and
it involves something we've been talking about
in the real world, which is the possibility
of asteroid mining in the future.
It is so well written.
The science in it makes it interesting and
I could not more highly recommend this book
Delta v by Daniel Suarez.
I tweeted about it the other day and a couple
of people treated me pictures that they had
already purchased the book.
That's a new fiction recommendation and then
an old classic fiction recommendation.
I'd never read this until a few months ago.
The Count of Monte Cristo by Alexandra Dumas.
Um, this, there are many versions of this
book.
Of course, it was not written in English.
This is as far as I know, an unabridged, oh
no, it is a translated and abridged by local
bear.
This is a great translation.
I recommend it.
It doesn't, it's not as long as some versions.
This one is still 500 pages, but it goes quick.
The Count of Monte Cristo is just one of the
best stories that has been told period.
A, it's a story of revenge.
It is a story of entrepreneurship, I would
say.
Um, it's just a great book.
So all of these and many other recommendations,
go to David pakman.com/recommendations.
Use the links on that page to get these books
and then you will be supporting the David
Pakman show in so doing.
And also, if you buy any of these books, most
authors are now on Twitter, not Alexandra
Dumas.
He's been dead for a long time, but many authors
are on Twitter.
I recommend if you get these books, help the
show get attention in an organic way by tweeting
to me and the authors.
I bought your book because David Pakman recommended
it.
And, uh, I'll do another one of these in a
couple of a couple of weeks.
If people are interested.